hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2018 candidates tournament
here we have a game between Alexander
Greece Chuck and the Fabiano Caruana now
it doesn't actually mean anything for
Greece Chuck to win this game since he
doesn't really stand a chance of winning
the candidates he did mess up that game
against shark dear mommy they are off in
the previous round but if a biana wins
this game then it doesn't matter how all
of the other games will will finish if
he wins the game he wins the candidates
tournament as he is a half a point in
the lead before the start of the final
round but you know you can know you you
can't really say if you're gonna win the
final round so it's it's extremely
important for everyone else to win as
well if mommy tiara wins he has
excellent chances of winning the
candidates and Cara Kane is playing
against Dean Liron so even a hurricane
ending leader and still have a chance of
winning the candidates so it's a very
exciting a last round and before before
we actually see the game let's let's
check out some of the photos here we
have a nice photo of Fabiano also from
from round 14 here we have a nice
close-up of Alexander Greece Chuck
here we have that's a photo from above
there we have a nice power bar on the
right side of the table
Fabiano is a Fabiano came prepared for
the final round and I don't know if I
will be doing the game mam eti of vs.
kramnik so in case I don't hear a couple
of photos here is Kramnik shaking hands
with Anatoly Karpov
here we have Anatoly Karpov making the
first move for Vladimir Kramnik in the
game against Mahmoud Europe and here
just a nice close-up of Anatoly Karpov
as you know if I have a nice photo of
corporal I will show it so that being
said let's see this game so Richard
decided to open with E for and by now
you already know if you play e4 against
Caruana in the candidates now he did
prepare the Petrov defence so II five
nine two have three Knight to f6 he does
go for the petrov and d4 Knight captures
on e4 and now he captures on e5 this is
a line I've never actually seen before
but I've heard it's it's been played d5
now
and Knight B to d2 you could also
capture on Poisson but to this only
would help black develop doesn't really
do anything for white so Knight B to D
to Knight captures the Bishop captures
and Bishop to e7 Bobby
prepares the castle Bishop to d3 we have
c5 now with the threat of pushing c4 c3
Knight to c6 and here castles Bishop to
g4 rook to e1 Queen to d7 and now h3
Bishop to h5 and now Bishop to f4 Queen
to e6 we have we have a three castles
and the now b4 h6 and the better of the
g3 here the district has the idea of
going night to d4 Knight to d4 with the
idea of attacking this Queen oddly
placed on e6 and he wants to exchange
Queens with the idea that now this the
queen will capture the bishop on h5 so
the bishop will have to capture the
Queen the problem here is after Bishop
captures Queen and Knight captures Queen
and e6 after black recaptures the
knighted this also opens up a discovered
attack from the roof to the bishop so
you don't really have time to capture
this bishop as you lose your Bishop on
f4 so before going into this Bishop to
g3 and getting the bishop out IDF file
b6 now and night to d4 now this becomes
an option but rip capture suddenly one
night captures on e6f captures on e6 and
rook a rook a captures on d1 and C for
Bishop - see - and now b5 a4 a6
protecting the b5 pawn f3 and now Bishop
to g5 Bishop to f2 going for that c5
square Bishop to f4 now Bishop to c5
attacking the rook on f8 so rook rook to
d8 and now Bishop to d6 and here Fabi
plays Bishop to g3 and now you can see
how this Bishop on g3 is is is really
constricting the movement of the White
King here and always what will what will
have to be very careful about this a 5
point as both denied and Bishop are
attacking it so this rook can never
really
go anywhere and another thing white will
always have to be careful about an idea
like rook captures and e6 pawn captures
and Bishop captures as this would create
a massive pawn Center for black but okay
rook to e2 getting the rock out of the
way and now g5 fixing the points here on
f3 and nh3 and also after this idea with
this Bishop is resolved maybe an idea
like 97 to g6 - maybe f4 or h4 will also
be an option so King to f1 King to have
7 and now Bishop to c7 attacking the
rook rook to e8 and now Grichuk returns
the Bishop to d6 saying to Fabi if you
want to beat me with the black pieces if
you want if you want to win the
candidates I'm just gonna play my brush
back to d6 you figure out a move you
figure out how to continue this game
without repeating as district doesn't
can't really win anything with this game
okay he can win some rating but he could
also lose some rating but Quran of
course has to win this game so he plays
rook a to c8
rook back to a 1 and now preparing as
fabi's rook left da file now a capture
Samba file will be an idea and doubling
up rooks on the a file rook eat a
Vietnam as now fabi's rook is the Iraqis
nc800 Bishop to c7 is no longer an
option
bishop to be one and now rook to d7
we have rook to a3 d for a capture some
b5 a capture some v5 and seek after
sandy for Knight captures on d4
attacking the rook rook 8 rook e - a -
now doubling up on the a file with the
threat of rook rook coming to a 7 here
nice to see 6 now the Knight is guarding
the a7 square and now on Bishop to e4
threatening threatening to capture the
night and then if infiltrate the
position with rook to a 7 but here
Bishop captures on e5 grabbing that pawn
and you can't really recapture here with
Bishop chapters 95 because you get nice
capture Sun on e5 and now black simply
want to pawn so after Bishop captures on
e5 Bishop
actors on c6 and now rook captures on d6
official capture some b5 grabbing back
the pawn now rook to d1 check King to e2
and now rook to g1 threatening to pick
up this pawn and then all of the other
points will fall as well and here King
to e3 now the rook from a2 is also
guarding the g2 pawn if instead of if
instead of King to e3 something like
into f2 was played with the idea of
protecting with the King and also
attacking the rook forcing the work to
move simply brush up to D for checking
the King also defending the rook King
would have to go to g3 and then c3 and
it becomes very dangerous for white so
instead Grisha goes for King to e3 and
now we have rook to be 1 and going for
the b4 pawn rook to a7 check King to
have six and now Bishop to d7 attacking
the rook and c8 and also attacking the
e6 pawn which will in the future create
a threat maybe of rook to a 6 with a
double attack on the undie 6 pawn bishop
to a4 check King to e2 and now rook to D
8 attacking that Bishop here a rook to
c2 was played there's there's really no
no good way of defending the b4 pawn if
you try something like rook to a4 to try
and defend it then then you're then
you're losing the game instantly because
rook to be to check you have to move
King to f1 to protect the pawn and now
comes Rock to d2 with a double attack on
your Bishop and e7 you move the bishop
and you get to checkmated so that would
be very unfortunate
so after this rook to d8 move there
there is an option of actually going
rook to a6 now may be taking advantage
of of the pin on d6 pawn but it doesn't
really work for white rook to be to
check again King to f1 but now black has
the option of playing rook captures on
d7 sacrificing this exchange and after
rook captures now c3 and white has no
way of stopping this pawn white would
have to give back the exchange rook to
d1 C - now you look to e1 and now after
black brings out the win now first of
course you capture with checking moves
and now
you could give a couple of checks but
the black king will hide on h5 so you
can't gain any perpetual checking ideas
here you would have to capture the Queen
and after Bishop captures rook to his ex
check King moves and after loop three
for defending you would be up a bishop
you would be down to pause but two
points but it's it's a winning game for
black so not a lot of options here for
Greece Chuck so he decided rope the c2
he's gonna try to try and locate the
position but he does have to give up the
b4 pawn so rope captures on before by
Fabi Bishop to c6 now preparing Bishop
to b4 c3 and now rook to d7
also you don't really have the option of
capturing this pawn that's that's pretty
obvious because rook to d2 check King
moves and rook to B 1 this will be
checkmate after after white gives up the
rook
so after this C to remove rook to d7
first offering a trade of rooks
and now rook the c8 instead of this
group to see it rook to be to was also
an option with the idea that after King
to be one as you can't really afford to
grab the rope can be to Kingdom one rook
D to be 8 now and after Bishop to b4 now
rook to b4 and this would gain a lot of
activity for black so this would have
been a faster way to to go about this
position but okay after rook to these 7
rook to c8 we have Bishop to e4 and now
h5 so here if you look at this position
the material is pretty equal but a favi
does have a past C pawn and there's
really there's really no way white can
do white white can threaten anything
here and it's interesting at this point
this is move 46 here when Fabi pushed h5
it was actually at this point that the
game mama D our versus Kramnik ended in
a draw and also Sergei Sergei drew his
game against the Dean liver and
basically all of the other games were
drawn aside from this one this one was
still being played so here after far
we've pushed h5 he could have just
offered a draw and he would win this
the tournament as a draw is now enough
for him because all of the other games
were drawn as well but it's it's hard to
say maybe he was maybe he totally wasn't
paying attention to the other results
maybe he just he just wanted to win this
game even though a draw was sufficient
to win the tournament but you know there
are some ideas why he would continue
this game firstly he can't really lose
this position he would have to blunder
like a whole work or something to
actually be able to lose this game
another thing is if he wins this game
he's coming back to the 2800 Club and
another thing is a cousin was also in a
similar situation in the candidates
tournament where a draw was sufficient
for him to actually win the tournament
but he didn't want to draw he continued
to win the game
so maybe Fabi also wanted to send a
message to constant as his future
challenger but okay whatever the reason
the Fabi decided to play this game on
and the grease truck didn't offer a draw
either so came to d3 rock to be to now I
would have kicked back to e2 when
outcomes h4r up to d1 and now King to e5
rock to a one Rock to d8 rook to d1
again rook to b8 rook to a1 and now
Bishop the d2 preparing to bring the
King all the way f4 to g2 g3 rock to a6
and now comes Rock to d8 rook to c6 and
now rook to be one king - f - and now
rook to a1 a king to f4 again it was
possible but you know as Fabi doesn't
want to draw this game he wants to win
if he doesn't want to give up give up
points for nothing although this would
be winning after Bishop - you even check
King e2 and now Bishop to g3 with this
rook coming T 1 this would be this would
be completely winning but ok after him
to f2 r up the c4 we had a solid rock to
a-1 first group to c4 rook to d4 now I
roped the c8 of course avoiding the
exchange rope the before King to e2 and
now
into a for finally bringing the King
into the position King to F to now rook
the b1 preparing some checkmating ideas
a rook to f8 check King to e5 and now
Bishop to d3 rook to be to and now comes
King e to rook to e1 check King F to and
rook to see one here there's really
normal moves for white you do have to
get through the rook rook captures pawn
captures and now rook to b8 preventing
this pawn from being Queen but now comes
Bishop to c3 defending the pawn bishop
to e4 Bishop to d4 check King e2 and now
King to f4 rook to be four now five
protecting the bishop on d4 rook to b7
and here after King to g3 it was finally
in this position that Alexander Grichuk
resigned the game as he he really
doesn't have any more moves to play he
would have to play f4 first and give up
this pawn and then all of the other
pawns would fall and he doesn't want to
he did all he could he really tried but
in the end there was really nothing
nothing else he could do so yeah
basically all in all
Fabiano Caruana is the winner of the
2018 candidates tournament and he is the
one that will be challenging Magnus
Carlsen in November in London but even
though it that match will only will
happen in November you will already in
four days there's a tournament called
the Greinke chess classic and for both
Fabiano and cos and we'll be playing
there so chances are they will already
meet at that tournament Levin Aragon
will also be playing in that tournament
Vishy Anand will be playing there holy
fun will be there a lot of strong
players will be there I even so they
even made a trailer about the tournament
so I'll I will put a link to the trailer
for this tournament in the description
below so feel free to check it out it's
under Greg Branca chess classics a
youtube channel so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoy the game I do hope
you enjoyed all the photos I have given
you throughout these games and I hope
you enjoyed the entire coverage of the
2018 candidates tournament I will put a
link with all the games from the
candidates in the description below and
I'll have to see a
I don't know if I will be covering any
more games maybe if I missed like an
interesting one although although I
don't think I have so that's it the
tournament is over and I will I will
probably be covering the Greinke chess
classic that starts on the 31st of March
so yeah probably gonna probably gonna do
some at all versus botanique games until
then pretty sure I could cover about
eight or nine nine games maybe even
finish the entire match so yeah once
again thank you for watching as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
and once again I would like to thank
Nikki for sending all of the photos from
every round so we can enjoy the photos
in real time all of the links to our
social media will be in the description
below so if you enjoyed chests if you
enjoyed photography
feel free to follow her work and yeah
that's it thank you and I will see you
soon